the nile river has overflowed and
covered its entire surroundings except
for the tip of the great pyramid in giza
egypt an expedition was sent to find how
high the water had risen
the people measured the edge of the
pyramid that's above the water and found
it was 72 meters long so this distance
right over here 72 meters
they knew that the entire length of the
edge is 180 meters when it's not flooded
so this entire length is 180 meters they
also knew that the vertical height of
the pyramid is 139 meters so this is 139
meters what is the level of the water
above the ground so the ground is right
over here at the base of the pyramid and
so they want the level of the water
above the ground so that's this height
this height right over here so let's
just call that h we want to figure out
what h is
round your answer if necessary to two
decimal places
so what do we know and what do we not
know so they've labeled this little
angle here theta and this of course is a
right angle so this angle here at the
base of the pyramid this is going to be
the complement of theta it's going to be
90 degrees
minus theta
and using that information we can also
figure out that this angle up here is
also
is also going to be theta if you don't
if you don't if that looks a little bit
strange to you let me just draw it out
here and make it a little bit clearer
make a little bit clearer if we have a
triangle a right triangle where this
angle right over here is 90
minus theta and we wanted to figure out
what this is up here let's say this is x
well we could say x
plus 90 minus theta 90 degrees minus
theta plus 90 degrees
plus 90 degrees is going to be equal to
well the sum of the tr of the angles of
a triangle are going to be 180 degrees
well if we subtract 180 from both sides
so that's 100 and that's 100 that's 180
from the left 180 from the right we get
x minus theta is equal to zero or if you
add theta to both sides x is equal to
theta so this thing up here is going to
be theta as well
so this is also going to be theta and
what else do we know well we know that
this is 72 we know that the whole thing
is 180. so this is 72 and the whole
thing is 180 the part of this edge
that's below the water this distance
right over here let me draw it without
cluttering the picture too much doing
the black color this distance right over
here is going to be 108
108 plus 72 is 180.
so what does this do do for us we need
to figure out this height we need to
figure out this height we know that this
right over here is a right triangle
this right over here is a right triangle
i could color this in just to make a
little bit clearer this thing in yellow
right over here is a right triangle
if we look at that right triangle and if
we wanted to solve for h and solve for h
using a trig ratio based on this angle
theta right over here we know that let's
see relative to this angle theta
relative to this angle theta this side
of length h is an adjacent side
and
this length of 108 right over here along
the edge that's the hypotenuse of this
yellow triangle that i just highlighted
in so which trig ratio involves an
adjacent side and a hypotenuse
oh we just write sohcahtoa
soca
toa sine is opposite over hypotenuse
that would be this distance over the
hypotenuse cosine is adjacent over
hypotenuse adjacent over hypotenuse so
we get the cosine
of theta is going to be equal to the
height that we care about that's the
adjacent side of this right triangle
over the length of the hypotenuse over
108 well that doesn't help us yet
because we don't know what the cosine of
theta is
but there's a clue here theta is also
sitting up here so maybe if we can
figure out what cosine of theta is based
up here then we can solve for h so if we
look at this theta what is the cosine of
theta
and now we're looking at a different
right triangle we're looking at this
entire we're looking at this entire
right triangle now based on that entire
right triangle what is cosine of theta
well cosine of theta once again is equal
to adjacent over hypotenuse the adjacent
length is this length right over here we
already know that's 139 meters so it's
going to be equal to 139 meters and
what's the length of the hypotenuse
well the hypotenuse is this length right
over here it's 72
72 plus 108 or we already have it
labeled here it's 180. we can assume
that this is an isosceles this this
pyramid is an isosceles triangle so 180
on that side 180 on that side so the
cosine is adjacent 139 over the
hypotenuse which is 180
over 180 and these these datas are the
same data we just showed that so now we
have cosine of theta is h over 108
cosine of theta is 139 over 180 or we
could say that h over 108
which is cosine of theta also is equal
to 139 over 180 both of these things are
equal to cosine of theta now to solve
for h we just multiply both sides by 108
so h is equal to 139 times 108
over 180. so let's get our calculator
out and calculate that
so that is going to be
139
times
108
divided by
180 gets us to
83.4 meters so h is equal to
83.4 meters the height of the water is
83.4